you're welcome to this video playing
blitz game against international master
shimmy from the UK let's check briefly
Simon and so from London ok not really
familiar familiar with this player we
got a Slav let's see taking a bit of
time here ok the midline and they form
is designed to prevent be 5 i'm going to
play them and then tried and trusted
classical mainline term now there are
various moves Queenie to a small of them
intending to play you fall and black and
only hear ya can also do that ok hmm not
quite sure I Bishop d3 is right ok been
a while since I looked at this opening
and now is it if five no I think it's
Bishop f4 first but I'm not one hundred
percent sure maybe mp5 is right
interesting
hmm yeah not sure does he really want to
take on c3 I doubt bad maybe how to
react I can I can play five but i'm not
sure that really but he 5 white wait
when did I play five am i threatening
bishop age seven yeah we can take on a
three though but if okay let's play a
five took me far too long okay he took
on f3 because of the bishop h7 business
ki am coming takes and what's now yeah I
thought that 94 is a possible idea he
can take though maybe just this move
now doesn't feel right to give him the
bishop with a move like 95 he cannot
grab a pro-nazi 3 because H 793 bc
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
Bishop h7 check I don't win the Queen
the most amazing thing about all this is
that has spent so much time on this not
too spectacular position okay how to
continue maybe go here and try to play
with f4 f4 f5 yeah he probably really
threatens to to get the pawn I've
protect III least for the moment
I can maybe just play see 5 a move like
that attacking the center and maybe I
can respond something like Bishop b5
yeah here we go there should be five I
was thinking don't have much time need
to increase the speed the ideas if the
removes the night i can probably take d5
and have this idea to play night in sick
so if i take here
d 7 is hanging am ed Bishop d7 now I
think I'm winning material here yeah I
winning material him quite substantial
material in rock d 79 f6 is the big
problem and Bishop see one i also have
Knight f6 so i can take yet with both
wins so i can i can take care moist air
better more this is really good enough
just take the central pawn or black
forfeits Katie disconnection yeah this
is a really popular way to give up on a
game just disconnect all right so I very
quickly went down here from prophet Lee
a good position i am i'm not sure what
he should play maybe we can go back some
loose because it's interesting okay five
he took yeah now yeah i can also take d5
the seat a bit dull to me but maybe it
is a good idea just grab him ah this is
important i was actually a bit concerned
about Queen takes but i have to show me
for this is not playable just wins the
house okay yeah maybe i should have
taken night before i was also thinking
about but giving up this bishop doesn't
really feel right so i returned to d2
which is probably not too bad rook e8
and okay
wanted to provoke weakness I was
expecting night f8 to be asked not
weakening squares okay the ITA needs to
do something else I guess c 5s is so
tricky this is in fact not even the best
move but it is a good computer approves
but 95 seems to be even better Bishop e2
and now walk c5 I didn't see that one
check some very nice this is very nice
for white this eight hanging h7 hanging
there should be five threat 9070
possibility yeah very good position for
white ok my move is not not bad and in
fact after his response it becomes
instantly winning after 95 there's no
move now they can take care but Bishop
e7 is just this is just winning I can
even take here and then take yet very
have very little to hope for us black
yeah and it's just one decisive material
yeah i can go download really quickly
with the one careless move like c5
alright thanks for watching